>> Sorry, the fake laugh got me. What the Size of New Jersey,
Israel. Why can't they NOT HAVE ISRAEL? ONE COUNTRY, tiny nation.
I don't think there's a problem with anybody wanting to have
an ethno-state. When Israel takes over the planet, when they're
the world hegemon, just like the United States, you and your
ancestors won't even be fit to press the buttons on elevators,
okay? You go in the mines.
So, the first thing we're going to start with is this this Asmongold
versus Hasan story, all right? Okay, Asmongold reacts to Hasan
[__] denying 40,000 people were killed in the Iranian
protests. That's what kicked off this entire back-and-forth that
Asmon and Hasan have been doing over this one take, all right?
Basically, Hasan is is going to laugh when this Fox News segment
says 40,000 people were killed in the crackdowns on protesters,
and then it's all going to pick up from there. At the end of
the day, I agree with you. Radicalism of any sort is bad, which
is why this maggot >> They killed 40,000 people, man? No,
they
No, they didn't. You're a goddamn idiot if you think that, okay?
You're a How do you know that? >> sorry. They did not kill
40,000 people, dumbass. They did kill a [__] ton
of people in the process of of How do you
Like I I don't even understand this. Uh suppressing the the I
mean, why do you think they turned off the internet?
Like I mean, really, think about it for 3 sec. Why would they
turn off the internet if they weren't going to kill a bunch of
people?
protests that that took place, which by the way, America and
Israel openly admit that they played a role in, okay? Trying
to assign ownership of the protests against the government that's
literally, by his own admission, systematically killing their
own people, then assigning ownership of it to Israel and uh America.
No.
I think like the ownership is like
The ownership is like 2 to 5%. Now, maybe you can increase that
knowing that economic sanctions drove a lot of this, okay? Possibly,
but it's not that big a deal. >> Maybe, yeah. Maybe Israel
and America helped because they thought that it's bad to kill
your own pro It's not that big a deal to point out that no, that's
not what he's saying. It's not that big a deal to point out that
America and Israel did things that led to this precise
going down the way it did, okay?
It's not a problem to do that. You should point that out. >> protesters
just because they want to change the government.
The people weren't doing anything wrong. He just justified mass
murder of civilians because of Israel? As I've said before, Hasan
will always fall off on the side of defending, rationalizing,
justifying,
and downplaying Islamic terrorism.
He will So, before January,
Benjamin Netanyahu, at the behest of apparently his Mossad, went
to Trump and said, "Hey, we could cause a popular uprising here.
Hey, we have like the people on the ground. We could do a popular
uprising here. We'll We'll have to nudge it, we'll have to nudge
it, but we can get it done, okay?" And we're supposed to believe
that despite Bibi Netanyahu, the Mossad chief, and multiple US
people all saying, "Well, Mossad was obviously there, and they
were doing [__] there." We're supposed to believe
that no, they had nothing to do with this.
that's not to take away from the genuine hatred a lot of people
had for the Islamic Republic and for the regime there. That did
happen.
They There was real anger towards the country, okay? But also,
there's like another There's a another exacerbating factor here
that's going on, okay? And it is not inherently supporting of
terrorists to point that
All right, we watched We We read this article. We've read a couple
of these other articles. All right, it's very obvious that Israel
was trying to cause some sort of popular uprising in this country,
all right? Anyway, we can
>> Every single time. Right? But they did not kill 40,000
people in 2 days. Like you're you're unbelievably dense. You
have It was 3 days, idiot. convinced yourself. It doesn't even
It doesn't even matter. Like them killing 10 people is >> even
matter. still [__] up. Yeah.
>> That's the That's the comment again. It doesn't even
matter. It shouldn't Even if they killed like way fewer people,
you should still be upset about it. Oh, yeah, you're saying it
doesn't matter at all. Okay, you don't even care about this.
No, he's saying literally if you You should care about it. Either
way, come on, man. I've never heard a consistent number on this
from people that just turn around and say, "Oh, they killed,
you know, 80,000 people." I've heard 80,000,
ridiculous. Jesus Christ, how do you not recognize that? It's
like this is
to actually justify American and Israeli intervention.
But there's no propaganda about Palestine. The amount of people
that were killed in Palestine is a defined number that nobody
can ever question. But whenever Iran intentionally takes off
the internet, they shut down the entire internet, they bust in
Iraqi militia forces, and there are leaked videos of people being
massacred in the streets, then no, actually, well, we don't know
how many. Guys, it There's no way it was that
Oh my god.
That's what you're leaning into.
And also, do you want to know why people originally said it was
10,000? >> Well, last year he said he was 40 years old.
This year he says he's 41. Which one is it? He's lying. He's
got to be lying. Why is he giving us different answers? Oh my
god.
Asmongold's whole point here is that the reason the number went
up is because it's been longer and more people have died, I guess.
>> is it. And again, Hasan will always fall off on the
side of justifying,
making excuses for, and sometimes even passively supporting Islamic
terrorism. >> Like he did with the Houthis, and also like
he did with Hamas. So, really, that's what you can expect from
somebody like Hasan, and this will always be the case. And again,
you can take this to the bank, and other people like him will
do the exact same thing. Every single time they will do this.
And Hezbollah, yes, falls on the side of terrorism every single
time. It's because they're terrorist supporters. That's the reason
why. It's literally that simple. They want the terrorists to
win. They want the Islamic uh extremists to win. And so, what
>> Asmongold is just doing the thought-terminating thing.
They support terrorists. They support terrorists. They hate America.
They hate America. They say, "Death to America."
He's doing it, you know? We We pointed it out before. >> they
try to downplay their bad actions, and then overplay the bad
actions of people that are against them. That's what they do.
It's It's I mean, obviously, I mean, duh. Like how do you passively
Well, yeah, I mean, by not going after He very actively supported
the Houthis, so I don't know why Asmongold's saying passively
here. He could totally get away with just saying he supported
the >> I'm not bringing these things up. So, yeah, that's
it.
It's weird when people hedge on something that they should just
know, right? Oh, he like even passively supported No, he totally
actively did it. Why are you hedging about something that is
literally everyone knows that you've reacted to. You've pointed
out multiple times on your stream.
Crazy, man.
I'll probably do a 6.5 out of 10 Abomination impression. Maybe
not. Not off the top of my head, okay? So, then
watches Asmongold have this reaction. He follows it up, okay?
does bring it into focus the real deal Asmon's most recent response
about Iran to you >> systematically killing their own people,
then assigning ownership of it to Israel and America. No, maybe,
yeah. Maybe Israel and America helped because they thought that
it's bad to kill YOUR OWN
IF JUST
YOU KNOW, I don't think America's always bad. But if you ever
make the argument that America is helping because they just want
to help people, because they just want people to be doing better
in the world. No, that's not why America has ever done this.
That's not why America has ever done this. It's not why America
does anything. Come on.
Hasan's fake laugh is an L? No, it's not. It's kind of funny
to me. It's The other one's way better, though.
>> When he laughs like that, that's way better. guy who
literally said regime change wars and like democratizing Iraq
is a
Queen Anisa is live? Oh my god. We got any more We got any more
impressions today? Oh, she's just starting. Never mind. spectacular
Never mind. failure and didn't work, and now heavily leaning
into that exact same narrative at a time when the American government
isn't, right? Donald Trump is not even doing this. Donald Trump
is basically saying, "Yeah, we're doing it for oil. Who gives
Well, it's actually It's worse than that. It's
Cuz Israel's still doing this. Israel's still running with the
narrative that like maybe a popular uprising will happen. And
like Iranians Iranians, take to the streets. You can take your
country back, right?
Bibi does that knowing full well that his own intelligence service
and the American intelligence service have both said, "If these
people take to the streets, if they protest, they will be killed
immediately." And Bibi's out here like, "No, you have to go go
protest. You can take back your government." Trump had to tell
Bibi, "Stop Stop doing this. You're going to get people killed.
You are going to get people killed, Bibi. Stop."
We're going to bomb everyone in Iran.
And and Asmongold is like holding on to this idea that like there
is a some kind of democracy
at play here, some kind of liberal some kind of liberation at
play here.
Also, same guy who has demanded that the American government
kill protesters.
Same guy who has said America should kill more protesters and
put them in concentration camps is now talking about how like
we're actually blowing up Iranian bridges,
you know, blowing up the Pasteur School of Medicine that's been
around since 1920
that actually
created indigenous COVID vaccine.
We're doing that to liberate the Iranian population somehow.
No one believes this. This is unbelievably stupid. I don't even
think Asmongold believes this. He just has no other option here.
Just because they
I'm pretty sure Asmongold doesn't even know all those things,
but it's fine.
>> The people weren't doing anything wrong.
He just justified mass murder of civilians because of Israel.
As I've said before, Hassan will always fall off on the side
of defending, rationalizing,
justifying,
and downplaying Islamic terrorism.
[laughter] They
They did Islamic terrorism to our F-15 fighter jet earlier today.
Did you guys
Okay, this is This is something people have genuinely been saying,
so I don't mind him talking about this. People have genuinely,
as he downplays it, wait. He's not downplaying it. Hold on.
Hey, I understand you guys are like totally mind poisoned against
Hassan. I understand that. But he's not downplaying it. People
have unironically news agencies have run with the idea that Iran
is increasing tensions by shooting down a fighter jet that is
bombing their country.
When When this jet got shot down, people have said
People have unironically said THAT IRAN IS INCREASING TENSIONS.
IRAN IS PROVOKING THE US.
YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND HOW STUPID that is and how how insane
it feels to read that from some paper in the US, okay? Like that's
that's the crazy thing to me is that they're literally saying,
oh well, why is Iran trying to like increase tensions while we're
Well, I don't know, man. Probably
It's probably something like you're bombing their country. You're
threatening to kill all their civilians by killing by destroying
their electricity, preventing them from purifying their water.
How could they increase tensions by launching missiles in their
own airspace like that? It's terrifying, man. Iran has to be
stopped.
Goofy, okay? But I will say I do agree Hassan does downplay like
actual terrorism sometimes. I just think the terrorism when it's,
you know, with regards to Israel and what's happening in Gaza,
I don't know that I fully back that being terrorism. If Hassan
came out and said today America, you know, deserved 9/11. I would
denounce that. I would denounce that.
They did Islamic terrorism to our US Air Force A-10 Warthog
when it crashed near the Strait of Hormuz. That was really [__]
up the way that they did Islamic terrorism to
you can
You guys understand that there's a reason Iran is like people
are going back 47 years to make this about the US,
Cuz while Iran did use proxies to try to go after Israel to try
to nip at the heels of Israel, okay?
Those Those proxies were not doing a ton to go after the Americas
like in any
Like the best arguments I've seen are, well, Americans live in
Israel, so Americans are under threat of from Iran. Well, we
have bases in the Middle East, so we're under threat from Iran.
So while those groups, you know, I don't I don't necessarily
like those groups, it's not like they're a threat to the
Which Asmongold constantly tries to say they are. up, dude. It's
Islamic terrorism when you say Israel shouldn't do a genocide.
Asmongold has such a burning seething hatred for Arabs it can
only be matched
by the Israeli state, okay?
He He used to like America. He used to feel like he was America
first, but he's found that his hatred for Arabs can only be matched
by Israel itself, and so he he has fallen to supporting Israel
only,
Not America at all. Very sad, you hate to see it. Asmongold time.
Yeah, this is his new talking point about you regarding defending
Islamic terrorism. He's done it a few times recently. Yeah, it's
it's going to be um
It's going to have limited success, I think, as the situation
unfolds and as people start
having to reckon with uh
As people start having to reckon with like how unsuccessful the
American initiatives have been thus far,
as as more and more, you know, American US Air Force
assets are taken out,
they will realize that it's not you know, this kind of counter
narrative doesn't actually work. I'm just giving you an accurate
Dude, Asmongold is the shabbos [__] that you get
to press the big red button to nuke Iran during Shabbat.
>> This is one of the things that are happening. He is
in Well, yes, sir. Yes, sir, Mr. Netanyahu, sir. Yes, sir, Mr.
Netanyahu, sir. I'd love to I'd love to press that button for
you, sir. I'd I'd love to press that button for you, sir. Israel
is real tiny country size of New Jersey. Isn't it crazy that
they can't even have one country?
Some
that's the size of New Jersey, Israel, they can't EVEN HAVE THAT.
>> SORRY, THE FAKE LAUGH GOT ME. WHAT THE
DUDE, DUDE, I'M SORRY. HE LIKE HE LIKE PAUSED. If that was a
sincere laugh, he would wait He wouldn't be able to keep like
He pulled his gum out or his his his nicotine sa his uh Not a
Not a dip. What are they called? His nicotine pouch, whatever
the
Why can't I think of the name? His Zyn. Yeah, he pulled his Zyn
out. He wouldn't have been able to wait if that was a real laugh.
He like wait He like took the time to take his Zyn out before
he laughed. Israel that's the size of New Jersey, Israel, they
can't EVEN HAVE THAT.
I'M ISRAEL HI.
DUDE, that hot swap there on the Zyn is crazy, too. What the
Size of New Jersey,
Why can't THEY NOT HAVE ISRAEL? ONE COUNTRY, tiny nation.
Israel, size of New Jersey. No politic
>> Oh, he's so based, dude.
He's Mr. Based.
Dude, that's a next level Israeli accent. That's like on >> I
do I do appreciate like Asmongold's catalyst
fan base going from Holocaust denial and and anti-Semitism to
so quickly snapping back to defending
Dude, it's like they literally hate completely. They have a burning
hatred for his entire fan base. They only hold it back for long
enough to be like
Arabs are savages. We need to stand with Israel. That's like
the only time they can hold back their seething hatred for is
just when when are leading like a crusade, a genocide against
some Arab nation, okay? Or Persian nation in this case. That's
like the only time they can hold back that seething hatred. With
like talking points that were destroyed pretty much in the eyes
of the
all the way back in like, I don't know, December of 2023.
saying Israel's a tiny nation,
why can't they have Israel
is a talking point that doesn't even work in like 2024, let alone
2026.
My man's doing My man is uh mainlining Hazbara at this point.
It makes it worse. It makes it Dude, the amount of deaths you're
dealing out to everybody in your region is worse because you're
a tiny country, not
The amount of devastation you're laying out is worse.
It's not better. How do the do you think it's better?
It must be so embarrassing to be a mold man fan.
I think it's more so it's just if you're an Asmongold fan at
any point in your life, you already have dropped any sort of
self-reflection
capabilities. You're just you're incapable of of understanding
the way that uh the world views you, your world view, the guy
that you really appreciate.
But yeah, I mean, he went from saying Nick Fuentes is based for
doing Holocaust denial to hitting Hazbara lines, you know? And
and
>> Wait. Was that him or Oh, hold on. Do we need this disinfo
tracker thread?
Oh, never mind. It's a different thing. Went from saying Nick
Fuentes is based for doing Holocaust
This might be actually quite relevant to our next segment. Okay,
all of Asmongold's love and support for Fuentes might actually
be really awesome. >> denial to hitting Hazbara lines,
you
And and defending little old Israel here. Why can't they have
a little old genocide? I mean, come on.
I mean, bro, think about LIKE GOD DAMN.
>> PEOPLE ARE JUST NOT having it.
Just let Yeah, JUST LET THEM have it, man. God damn. Just let
them have a little bit of genocide, dude. Even his even his audience
is like not fully on board with it, but I guess they're not suspicious
enough of why he's doing this now.
But they did not kill 40,000 people in 2 days like you're you're
unbelievably dense. You have It was 3 days, idiot. That's not
it's just not true. That's not something that happened.
There's no evidence that that happened.
It's also
physically impossible for it to have happened and most people
Over the course of those protests
there probably was around like potentially up to 20,000 people
killed. I think is the number.
7,000 were confirmed. 11,000 were yet to be confirmed. They were
like basically people missing who had been detained. If they
killed every single person they detained, it would be somewhere
around like 18 to 20,000 at the top end. But that would be over
weeks of protests, right? It wouldn't be over it wouldn't just
be right away.
So the idea this number just keeps going up and up and up and
up.
Trump I believe 2 days ago said 45,000 >> Understand that
that is not a correct >> Thank you.
You know
This is unbelievably high number that is I mean unless they just
like blew up entire city blocks
Israel style
they just
They do they are not capable of of murdering 40,000 people in
such a short period of time.
Why doesn't it work? What They would be able to kill people that
quickly. They they would. I just don't think they did.
Right? Like they It's not like it would be impossible for them
to go and do that kind of purge. But I think if they'd done that
kind of purge where it was like 40,000 in 2 days, you'd see tons
of photos. There'd be photos I don't think you could do that
kind of purge and not get any evidence of it on the internet,
right? Like the best evidence we have of the the actual crackdown
that happened is like gunfire
in the crowds. Like there's there's gunfire happening around
protests,
Like there's just no reason to think it happened because there
is no like for that for this to have occurred, you need to like
in in the middle of Tehran have people in like a firing circle
just emptying entire AK clips into the crowd. That didn't happen
that way, right? >> Why doesn't like pro-Israel talking
points work? Have you looked at the polls recently? I mean this
is something that I repeat pretty much every day at this point.
It's become my mantra, but this is the most popular Israel will
ever be in the United States. Today is the most popular Israel
will ever
Also the the best evidence we have for the actual carnage that
happened had was broadcast by the IRGC themselves. Right? They
were broadcasting like hospital morgues and stuff filling up
with body bags. They were trying to intimidate people out of
protesting more.
Like they were they were trying to increase
what it looked like the number of people they killed because
they didn't want to go and like keep cracking down on people,
right? They wanted to intimidate people out of protesting. Not
a good impulse. I'm not saying that's a good impulse and it defends
them, okay? But I'm telling you that is the that is the source
we have for the amount of bodies or the IRGC going, "Yeah, we
killed a bunch of you. Do not protest
be in the United States going forward. Tomorrow Israel will be
less popular than it is today. Something to remember for all
the advocacy orgs that keep tying themselves to the genocidal
entity. Okay?
Or even Asmongold as a matter of fact. I mean going from
It is actually crazy that Asmongold's trying to go down with
the Israeli ship. That does seem Like with Asmongold I do wonder
sometimes people who like hop on the the Israel bandwagon like
somebody like Brianna Wu. I genuinely think that they are actual
anti-Semites who think they control the world and think like
jumping on the bandwagon means they're automatically going to
win. Do you know what I mean? Very sad. >> Palestinians
are are inferior people that deserve to be genocided
to then taking an anti-Israel slant when it became unfavorable
to defend Israel to then looping back around to defending Israel's
existence and Israel's violent
is a very interesting.
But I guess as I've said over and over again when your audience
is comprised of some of the dumbest people on the planet, they
don't necessarily punish you for contradicting your statements
from like a day prior.
Especially when they don't even get mad at Trump when he contradicts
himself in the same statement, right? Cuz Trump even in his address
in his presidential address literally started off by saying,
"Oh, we're saving the Iranian people." And ended the presidential
address by saying, "We're going to bomb Iran back to the Stone
Age
We're going to bomb Iran back to the Stone Age. We're going to
take out all the power plants and desalination facilities so
all the civilians die. And and you know destroying its bridges
and So those two things are at odds with one another, right?
But because the audience is unimaginably
they still believe it, I guess. Or they they delude themselves
into thinking that there is no contradiction here. >> 3
days. It It took them 3 days to do that. Convinced yourself.
It doesn't even it doesn't even matter like them killing 10 people
is >> It doesn't even matter. Still [__] up.
Yeah. Okay? Mhm.
I've never heard a consistent number on this from people. They
just turn around and say, "Oh, they killed you know 80,000 people."
I've heard 80,000 people 40,000. It's [__] ridiculous.
Shut >> I think. Technically cousins. Jesus Christ. How
do you not recognize that it's like this is propaganda
to actually justify American and Israeli intervention.
But there's no propaganda about Palestine. The amount of people
that were killed in Palestine is a defined number that nobody
can ever question. But whenever Iran intentionally takes off
the internet, they shut down the entire internet. They bust in
Iraqi militia for I'mma be honest if this is the best Israel
has as far as Hasbara is cooked. They're they're so done. Like
Israel's strongest Hasbara weapon now is a guy who doesn't You
say that. You say that, but they've been trust me, okay?
RFK knew you got to you got to get the out of the people's veins.
You got so many fat down in the southern United States. Asmongold's
basically Jesus Christ to them, okay?
I I wish I wish that were true that they're cooked cuz Asmongold's
a and all of his followers are but it's just not the case, okay?
I wish that were true. I wish it. BUT IT IS NOT TRUE, OKAY?
in [__] shower and is a Holocaust denier. What are
we doing?
What the [__] are we doing, you know?
An inconsistent worm that has no moral compass whatsoever that
will literally say unimaginably heinous anti-Semitic one day
and then the next day he'll turn around and be like the next
day he'll turn around and just like straight up repeat verbatim
Israeli talking points.
I'm sorry, but why is he even relevant?
I mean bought or not he has a fairly large audience still.
Obviously it's diminished
as you know Trump's popularity is
Even in the eyes of the dumbest people alive, which are the He's
got the biggest audience for like all of his content, too.
Let's not cope let's not cope too hard about it. He's got a massive
audience.
>> Euroid MAGA supporters.
Double [__]
Um you know
He's also He loves talking [__]
about me, but hates the prospect of talking to me.
But you know
times are changing.
Yeah, you'll never hear me cope about Asmongold's numbers. You'll
never ever hear me cope and say Asmongold is not like a massive
streamer doesn't get like massive numbers. He absolutely does.
He's doing crazy propaganda right now debating shits with Israeli
talking points being a debate pervert. But he's not he's not
smart enough or quick
to to actually defend Israel. Even if you were brilliant, it
would still be an incredibly difficult endeavor. Okay, we are
through the Hasan react. Okay, Asmon is up next. He's got a response.
Any caller? Very transphobic. >> Israel tiny country size
of New Jersey. Isn't it crazy that they can't >> That's
what I heard. I mean I I mean I Netanyahu said that, right? So
maybe it's not true. But I don't think Israel's that big, right?
I mean is it that big? I don't think so. Can't even have one
country.
Some [__] that's the size of New Jersey, Israel.
They can't EVEN HAVE THAT.
>> ISRAEL SIZE OF NEW JERSEY. ISRAEL WHY CAN THEY NOT HAVE
ISRAEL? ONE COUNTRY tiny nation. Israel size of New Jersey. No
politics here.
>> I mean you got to admit that it's kind of funny that
the Jews have been pushed out of He He thinks Does Asmongold
think that Hasan's disagreeing that it's the size of New Jersey?
Does he think that's where the disagreement is?
Does he think, "Oh, well, you know what? It is the size of New
Jersey, so I won the argument." There's no way he thinks that,
right? >> of like all these other Middle Eastern
And they're all in Oh, [laughter] hold on. >> I mean, you've
got to admit that it's kind of funny that the have been pushed
out of like all these other Middle Eastern countries.
And they're all in Israel, and even there people are getting
mad at them.
it's it's funny. Like it's
it's not funny.
They're all in Israel. >> in like I find it humorous, but
it's just the situation is so ridiculous
that it's funny with how ridiculous it is.
Uh he's so based, dude. He's missed I don't know. What What does
he think that means? What's the argument there?
It's ridiculous
that there are It's rid People are still mad at them even though
they have one country.
Why are they mad at them, Asmongold? What are they upset about?
Might it be totally flattening Gaza and
tens of thousands of people, including but tens of thousands
of civilians?
Why won't you actually say the thing? Why can't you say why people
are mad? People are so mad. They're just like jealous of Israel.
No, they're not. They're based. >> I do appreciate like
Asmongold's cattle ass fan base going from >> Just call
us Just call us You can do it. a cost tonight
Total cattle. Every single Asmongold fan, complete and utter
cattle.
Shame for a shame.
For shame, okay? You're not even fit to press the buttons on
the elevator, okay? That's how useless you are.
You'll go in a mine, all right? When When they take over, when
when the Israel when when Israel takes over the planet, when
they're the world hegemon, just like the United States, you and
your ancestors won't even be fit to press the buttons on elevators,
okay? You go in the mines. file and and I don't actually think
that's a risk, by the way. Just you know, we're doing memes for
the fun. denying the Holocaust now. I didn't know that. That's
That's
How about that? Wow.
uh anti-Semitism to so quickly snapping back to defending Israel
with like talking points that were destroyed pretty much in the
eyes of the
all the way back in >> great argument. Let's make an argument
to consensus. Let's say that a lot of people think this is wrong,
so that makes it wrong.
Why is it that there's never
Does Asmongold think he Does he think he lives in a an autocracy?
What is it What does he think the system of governance of the
United States of America is?
What is he What do you think What does he think Hasan is doing?
Does he think he lives in like a
Let's just make an argument to consensus. That's what you should
be
That is what you do. I know he knows this, right? It's what he
does all the time. He's like, "Oh, people think this, that's
what's right."
Yeah, yeah. No, no, no, no, no. He absolutely does this all the
time. He's just I guess out of arguments today? I don't know.
>> point in any of these clips where an argument is ever
presented. There's never any sort of a disagreement about this.
Like it It's crazy. You're wrong, he doesn't care. All I'm saying
everybody else cares. That's why he wants to shift off the topic
because everybody else cares. Everybody else is continuing to
care. So, he can say he doesn't care. He can be his normal, totally
psychotic self, right? And clap when people get killed and love
that, love watching people die in the streets of America, right?
But that's not most people. Most people think that's like ghoulish
and
That's most people. Never an argument, ever. Watch it back. If
you want to keep disagreeing, feel free to hop in the Discord.
You can come and argue these points on the stream. You're just
literally saying, "Wrong, he doesn't think that." No, he loves
watching people die. I've watched him I've watched him laugh
and cackle and clap when people are killed.
He loves watching it. It's very ghoulish. Most people think it's
very
You may not like that, but that is >> Like I don't know,
December of 2023,
Zaran Mozamdani is challenged by a Palestinian man who tells
them it's not your land to decide whether Israel has the right
to exist. THEY CONSTANTLY REAFFIRMED ISRAEL'S RIGHT TO EXIST.
OH, >> BECAUSE PEOPLE LIKE ME ARE CONSTANTLY ATTACKED BY
POLITICIANS FOR STANDING UP FOR PALESTINE, AND YOU ARE CONSTANTLY
DEFENDING THE RIGHT FOR ISRAEL TO EXIST. AND I'M HEARING YOU
SAY FREE PALESTINE, BUT ALSO ISRAEL HAS THE RIGHT TO EXIST. DON'T
BE HYPOCRITICAL. DON'T BE HYPOCRITICAL AND SAY FREE PALESTINE
WHEN YOU'RE ALSO DEFENDING THE RIGHT FOR Thank God we've imported
these sand wars into America, right?
Thank God that we have now these uh Middle Eastern blood feuds
that Does Asmongold not understand that Hasan's broad point would
just be not giving money to Israel? Like the point he used to
stand on business for all the
That's I I don't know if people like Do they misunderstand or
are they just
Are they just Or are they doing it intentionally? I don't know.
It's hard for me to tell. Are you intentionally misunderstanding
or what is going on here? Cuz the the furthest argument, like
the the most harsh argument people are making is cut off funding
to Israel. An argument, by the way, Asmongoy here used to make
all the time.
I assume he still does, but who knows. Listen, he's got a really
sweet deal pressing those elevator buttons, okay? Really sweet
deal for him. So, wouldn't be shocking if he changed his opinion
But he used to make the same opinion. That's the opinion Hasan
has. Just don't fund them. Stop funding them killing a bunch
of people. How hard is that? that are a thousand years old that
we're now putting front and center into American politics. And
now you have people from both sides of the sand wars that are
trying to uh manipulate the American public into thinking that
cheap picking their side is picking America's side.
Neither of these groups are on your
Get them out. It's so annoying.
Israel to exist. IT DOES NOT HAVE THE RIGHT TO EXIST. IT DOES
NOT HAVE THE RIGHT TO EXIST.
UH Is there not a far more effective group, Asmongold, in the
US who is on one side of that sand war convincing the US consistently
to go to war or to intervene on their behalf with regards to
those sand wars? You used to understand this, Asmongoy.
Where is the criticism at? Come on, man. Come I know it's there.
I know it's there. Deep down in your heart, I know it's there.
You could do it. YOU CAN RISE UP. >> YOUR LAND TO SAY IT
HAS THE RIGHT TO EXIST. WELL, HE'S RIGHT, ACTUALLY. >> the
They They take the right to exist. Nobody has any rights to do
anything. Nobody has a right to be alive. And if you do, then
if you have a right to be alive, then why can't somebody take
it away from you? It's Some people
What? If you have a right to be alive, then why can someone take
it away from
Then that's just saying rights don't
MY BRAIN. MY BRAIN. Why did he do that? THAT'S A PSYCHIC ATTACK.
WHAT THE The psychic He JUST ATTACKED ME PSYCHICALLY. WHAT DID
WHAT THE ASMONGOLD? Uncalled for. Uncalled for. You got to warn
me if you're going to say something that would That was crazy.
It's just an idea. I mean, they're all
Uh So, like Israel exists because they can defend themselves.
They don't exist because everybody else says it's okay for them
to exist. It's because Yeah, it's the force doctrine. Like that's
the everything is eventually
It is force doctrine. Yes, you do enforce rights for people based
on and and technically, there are not a lot of positive or negative
rights. It's what we agree as a society to give people. That
America literally is the kingpin of force doctrine in the world,
and America has decided you get certain rights in America. Yeah?
But But by the way, that has absolutely dick all to do with morality.
Does Asmongold never make an argument about morality, ever? He
certainly did when people laughed at Charlie Kirk, right? When
people laughed and celebrated Charlie Kirk dying, Asmongold got
on his high horse about morality and started doxing people and
trying to get them fired.
That's what Asmongold did. So, when he tells you when he tries
to do his thing, "Oh, well, they play to your emotions cuz they
they just want to manipulate
He's perfectly capable. He does it all the time. be backed up
by the force doctrine. That's That's the way it works. I mean,
it's just the truth.
Uh I I don't know.
It's too bad it didn't show the part with me saying that
I said I wondered if the 110th country that gets expelled from
will be Israel.
I'm sad that it didn't show that part of the clip. It's too bad.
Okay, I think we got further reactions to this. We need to keep
going here for a second.
And uh you did say that. I did.
ridiculous, wouldn't it? Why does it seem like the worst ideologies
in history carry forward into the future? Well, because there's
only so many of them, right? I mean, that's the reason why.
Was it on Shintor Scrolls?
I guess so.
Technically, they bought the swamp lands, made farms. I don't
know what they're going to do. It doesn't matter. I don't really
I don't care what goes on in the Middle East, really, to the
extent that it's like I mean, is Israel right? Is Israel Can
you imagine How hypocritical is this video? Hold on a second.
How insanely fake was this video? This is the most fake video
I've ever seen in my entire life. This is a travesty.
This video is embarrassing. Literally every element of this video
he's gone back on.
I bet you his house looks like now.
Guys, I've been a little too harsh. I've been a little too hateful.
I really I've been I made my friend Tipsout feel really like
gross with my with my Islamophobia, and I'm going to be better.
I'm going to be better, everybody. I'm going to be way better.
Where? Or when? When did that happen? Did we miss it? Did I miss
it?
What a [__] liar, man.
Jesus Christ. >> is Palestine right? Is Palestine wrong?
I mean, I don't know. Like it it's not really my thing. Like
I don't live
I mean, it's pretty easy to see that Iran is wrong because they've
they've they've been oppositional to America, right? They're
directly oppositional to America. If you're shilling for Asmongold,
get in the Discord. Come and talk. Use your voice. Use your big
boy words. Or [__] >> all the rest of it, I
can't. Yeah, just don't bring it here. Yeah, just don't bring
it here. I don't want to deal with
Part beaver was crazy. It was right,
What do you mean? are getting sponged, aren't there? Groups in
every country? Am I missing something? Actually, they're not.
So, if you want to look at after the formation of Israel, and
you look at the populations
in the different Middle Eastern countries, places like Iran,
places like Afghanistan. That's not technically Middle Eastern,
right? But like is Iran Middle I think I think Afghanistan is
Middle Middle Eastern, but maybe it's not.
I think
So, we're going to talk about how
they're ethnically cleansed from these
Okay. If that happened, that's really bad. Disavow that entirely.
Are you bringing this point up to make some point? Or you bring
this point up to virtue signal about how they've been ethnically
cleansed, too, without actually denouncing any kind of ethnic
Is that what we're going to do here? I wonder if that's the kind
of hypocrisy we're getting at. I think Iraq and Afghanistan are
two, and you can look at the populations going down massively.
>> been expelled from Arab countries cuz they're intolerant
and want their own ethno state.
I I I don't Again, that's the sand that that sand wars. Like
I don't know. You're literally talking about the sand
People are going to People are going to discuss the same topic
as you,
Really? Like I Oh, but No, no, no, you don't understand. So,
the Jews are actually wrong. Oh, no, you don't understand. Muslims
are actually right. Like I don't know. I don't know. Like you
guys deal with it yourselves.
Did you say sand wars? >> Yeah, am I wrong?
I just need you all to know I don't care about the sand wars.
I don't care about the sand wars at all. I'm just going to shill
for my side of the sand wars, okay? They pay me to press the
buttons in the elevator. I'm going to shill for that side. I
don't care about the sand wars, though, okay? I'm just going
to keep saying things that lead to Americans dying for the sake
of the sand wars, that lead to the American economy blowing up
for the sake of the sand wars. I'm just going to keep doing that
over and over, and then say I don't care about the sand wars.
Yemen. Oh, Yemen's another one, too.
Zionism's basically the right to have a
Which is kind of based. I don't see a single problem with the
Jews being able to have an ethno
I don't think there's a problem with anybody wanting to have
an ethno state. If Poland wants to be a white ethno state, if
Japan wants to be a Japanese ethno state, if China wants to be
a Chinese ethno state, or if you know, By the way, I will point
out this I'm not even going to criticize this. This is the only
argument you have for supporting Israel. You have to You have
to bite this bullet to make this argument for Israel. If you
want to make this argument, if you want to argue for Israel,
you want to argue it's all good, you have to say
And I do believe Asmongold believes this. I don't particularly
think it's morally wrong to want an ethno state,
Right? I just know a bunch of liberals go out who are vehemently
opposed to this in every possible way, and they will argue for
Israel. That's what baffles me. Asmongold saying this, this is
the least he's said all day. Canada wants to be a an Indian ethno
state, right? That's totally fine. You can do whatever you want
because you are a sovereign country, and you have the right to
do
And the thing that I think is ironic about this, right? Is that
I think it's like 18 to 20% of Israel
like it's like
I think it's like 20%, right?
It's a little bit under that, I think.
Yeah, it's 18% Yeah, yeah, there it is. So, like I mean, that's
not it's it's just it's just a factually not true. Like that
it it's a it's a
Israel in itself is not an it's not an ethno state.
That's actual rage bait right there. That's actual rage bait
right there. He is not that dumb. He is not that low
That's actually embarrassing. That That's the real rage bait
right there, >> Or there wouldn't be 18% Holy Ironically,
China is the biggest ethno state, 91% same ethnicity. Ethnicity.
I was born and raised, and so tired of I'm just joking around,
then.
How many ethno state It's not just population or structure. You
do need to have an ethnic majority.
Like I wouldn't say that it's an ethno state because you've enslaved
80% of your population. I don't think that's an ethno state.
Right? An ethno state is we only want I feel like
implied in ethno state is like we're going to have government
rules to make sure that this ethnic majority stays the ethnic
majority.
That's what I see it as, right? So, it's both the population
and the controls by the government. >> an issue if you
have multiple ethnicities in your in your country?
What about Druze? It's a it's an offset of Christianity.
It's also present in Syria, as well.
An ethno-religion.
Just like How bad is has Christianity dropped in the US? Give
it 10 years, the number will be almost 100%. Well, I don't know
about that. I have no idea.
Also, no, it won't. >> they have I mean, there's Arab Muslims
inside of Israel right now. So, I think that the narrative for
this is just that the ethno state narrative is just really not
very strong.
Nobody makes this Dude, I
Consistent. This is like
Dude, I'm like I'm attacking Asmongold, and he's returning fire,
okay? I'm the US right now. It's actually [__] up
for him to do psychic attacks on me while I'm streaming, while
I'm reacting to his content. It's [__] up for him
to do this, okay? To to say totally things that break my brain
completely, it's messed up, man. This drop cuz of illegal aliens.
Maybe a lot of them are are Catholic.
Saying it can't be an ethno state because Arab Muslims exist
in the country is a fundamentally thing to think. Why do you
think anti-American rhetoric has become so popular over the recent
years?
Because you have more people on the internet that are that are
not American.
I think that if you only had a Western internet, you'd probably
have way less anti-American rhetoric.
Like I think it's unironically
like if you give a billion Indians and Africans
internet, a lot of them are going to hate America.
This is where the next part is coming from. Oh, boy. This is
where our next segment is coming from.
>> Keep this That's a That's a key memory right there,
guys. It's a key memory, all right? We need to remember this
going forward. Key memory, cuz that's going to be very important
for the next segment, okay? He's starting to think, "Oh, only
Africans hate America. Only Only brownoids. Only total swarthoids
hate America, guys." I mean, obviously it's not 100%, but like
a lot of them don't have favorable opinions towards America.
It's just how it is.
>> I'm related. I still work and and leave jokes. Thanks
for your stream. Yeah, I appreciate it, man.
Yeah, I like usually doing you know, little like podcasts and
you know, talk to people and everything. I usually like doing
this.
How much further is this end? >> America gives internet
to the world, the world hates the internet.
That's solidarity.
Right here. This is This is the next thing I wanted to watch.
This part right here. That's just what I think is going to
Come on. Come on. I don't do ban appeals today. Walking in Mozart's
magical. Need to laugh. I I hope you enjoyed it. It was
Christianity isn't going down. Well, I was just saying like I
mean, that religion in general like goes down.
You playing Crimson Desert today? No, not today. Is it a binding
factor in order to have a coherent group? Oh, a binding factor
in order to have a coherent group. Yeah, sure. I think that's
true. Binding factor. Not a binding factor. >> the other
cheek too much. Well, I think Christianity has been co-opted
by people that have intentionally tried to neuter it and remove
its ability to
you know, create influence in the world. So, some
So, Christianity's been infiltrated by people who who have tried
to neuter it and reduce its influence in the world. >> the
line in the West, people psyop'd Christians into thinking that
being a good Christian is being obedient to people that want
to subvert you. And I think that what's happened is that there
are so many
Where'd you hear this from, Asmongold? I He He talks, and he
literally doesn't know the things he's doing at all. It's so
funny to listen to. That he'll sit here defending Israel, and
then he'll start rolling these lines out, and he doesn't understand
the connection. He's got no clue what he's saying. He's got no
clue how it's perceived by people with any amount of education,
any amount of like media literacy. He doesn't understand cuz
he has none of these things, right? Very >> into this psyop
and this manipulation
that you have I mean, even sometimes the Pope says things that
I I think are are not true. I think that they're not they're
not in line with with what Basically, what they do is they take
the entire page
and they take out one sentence and it's like Jesus said that
you should love your neighbor. And Jesus also and God also said
a million other things, but we're going to ignore all those and
we're just going to say this one thing. And loving your neighbor
means you have to give foreigners all your stuff.
So, they're effectively co-opting and using the religion
What? What Christian is saying that? You have to give foreigners
all of your stuff. Aside from Erodit
Aside from Okay, real Christians though, real Christians >> to
push a different ideology.
Pope only represents Catholics, not Christians. No, you're right
about that.
That's true. There's no way he thinks that's the Pope saying
that. And I think that's what's happened and I think that's the
big issue why Christianity the like you see I think a great example
of this this type of thing is James Tallarico.
I think That is what I was waiting for, for him to go in on Tallarico.
He thinks Tallarico trying to be kind is an example of the weakness
of Christianity.
He doesn't understand the point of Christian He doesn't understand
anything. This is very embarrassing to watch and listen to. >> example
of a bad actor who uses the Christian faith as a vehicle to push
uh ideology that's subversive to people that they're preaching
to.
Is it Trojan horse? He's not even a Trojan horse, he's just What
does he think So, I would love to hear that unpacked. What is
James Tallarico saying that is not a part of the Christian faith
that he's using to subvert people and make them think something
else? Cuz what I've seen of James Tallarico when he's talking
about faith, it's like how hey, even if you're an [__]
to me I still think you're an important person. You're You're
like a person I care about and I'm not going to stop loving you
or caring about you even if you're an [__] to me.
Very important tenant of Christianity of like actually actually
still considering other people human, never losing sight of their
humanity and their soul and their similarity to you in the eyes
of God. Very critical tenant of Christianity being explained
as subversion by Asmongold. >> It's literally the enemy
at the gates, right? It's nothing else really more complicated
than that.
Tallarico's a heretic? Yeah, I think he
I don't like what he's saying.
There's a There is a heresy
and
loves that heresy. That's the Christian Zionist heresy. He loves
that [__] Asmongold has never met a Christian Zionist
who he didn't want to suck off,
And yet, he wants to talk about some heresy. This guy being like,
"Oh, well, you know, I should We We love
apparently Coz are saying his stance on trans people. Okay, be
honest Coz, who talks to more trans people? Who has more friendships
with trans people? Who spends more time in in group chats with
trans people? The James Tallarico or Nick? Just be real for 2
seconds. Who loves trans people way more? James Tallarico or
Nick Fuentes? Be honest. Be honest.
I know you won't be able to be honest when you respond to me.
But yeah, I think that's really kind of what happened is that
um James not even close. You have to lie like that. That is That
is sad. But you You've gotten here just in time, Coz. You got
in here in time
John Doyle segment. So, I'm glad you're here, okay? >> Christianity
has been subverted in that way. And a lot of Christians don't
know how to
We shouldn't have Christians? No, Asmongold's not Christians.
Asmongold's trying to say Christianity's like super subverted
and then his point is James Tallarico. I'm sorry, James Tallarico
is not the point. Christian Zionists are the point. Christian
Zionists are the people who are being used. That's the schism.
That's the heresy that's being used to subvert the will of most
Christians in America, okay?
But he's not going to call that out, is he? Cuz like there's
like the problem is that like there's like two groups of people,
right? Cuz you have some people that are like that and then other
people that are also like, "Oh, we should bring back the Crusades
and like force everybody to be Christian." And like that's also
crazy. But the problem is that I think that the more people get
pushed, the more people push towards extremism. And I think that's
why it's
They get taken advantage of? Yeah.
Is Asmon an atheist? He is. He should shut the [__]
up.
He just also flipped the tables and
You say younger generations will
Anyway, I'm done with I'm done with this one. We're done with
this one. We have to finish the Hasan reacts segment, okay? We've
got one more reaction from for We have one more reaction from
and then we can go to the next segment, okay? Next segment going
to be even better. That's the Asmongold
react segment, okay? That's going to be Sorry, I have to add
to all these words and it gets very tongue twisty. >> Hasan
Oh, yes.
Okay, so Hasan Asmongold's going to take his second run, okay?
His second run at reacting to this. First run didn't go so well.
He's going to take his second run at it. Hasan calls out Asmongold
for being an inconsistent worm. Uh-oh, here we go.
Uh-oh, here we go. You already reacted to this, actually. Uh-oh,
here we go. I guess the the first run didn't go so well, I suppose.
>> [__] up, dude. It's Islamic terrorism when
you say Israel shouldn't do a
Thank you, As
>> So, you took my advice. Let me Let me go back. It was
It was turned down.
Uh you actually know Asmongold Asmongold actually knows that
Hasan said this before he gave the advice, I believe.
No? I think he I think he said it before Asmongold gave the advice.
Cuz Asmongold had already reacted to it. It's really [__]
up, dude. It's Islamic terrorism when you say Israel shouldn't
do a genocide.
Thank you, As
But I guarantee you there are to his audience to go, "He took
her advice. You so smart,
You so smart. I did well they picked you to put the elevator
buttons, Asmon. I I didn't work in the mines. You're like the
elevator guy. You're like You're the best of all." Well, it's
Islamic terrorism if they shoot a a rocket into
and they people from Israel
and they kill people from Israel. Yeah, it's Islamic terrorism.
They They literally say it.
It's not like it's a secret.
How many Iranians have people from
Or we just any any crime done by any person who may or may not
believe in the Islamic faith is on the head of every other Islamic
person in the world? Is that how we're doing it? Cuz that game
gets really old really fast. They say
My man is
mainlining Hasbara at this point.
It must be so embarrassing to be a Mold Man fan.
I think it's more so I It's just If you're an Asmongold fan at
any point in your life, you already have dropped any sort of
self reflection capabilities. You're just You're incapable of
of understanding the >> Is this going to be another 2-minute
rant with absolutely no argument or point of view that's being
put forward at all? that Don't tell me Don't tell me your world
view the guy that you really
>> that nobody can ever question. But whenever Iran intentionally
takes off the internet, they shut down the entire internet. They
bust in Iraqi militia force I'mma be honest, if this is the best
Israel has as far as Hasbara, it's cooked. They're They're so
done. Like Israel's strongest Hasbara weapon now is a guy who
doesn't
shower and is a holo
Yeah, he responded to what you said
Yeah, now he's just making fun of you.
You responded to what you said and now he's making fun of you
for being stinky.
Cuz he's a child. >> denier What are we >> What What
did I say the Holocaust wasn't real? What are we doing? If the
Holocaust was committed by a bunch of Hamas, do you think that
Hasan would be debating whether it was million or not? I bet
he would.
Does Hasan debate the kill counts from from October 7th?
Is he doing that?
Feel like if he's not going to do it there, it's far less likely
he would do it in the other case. an inconsistent worm that has
no What if I never been a Holocaust denier? By the way, I I don't
I don't even know where this came from.
I'm a holo When did I ever say that?
compass whatsoever. The >> So, wait wait a minute. So,
now Okay, let me get this straight.
I'm the first person
to both deny the Holocaust
and also be Israel's strongest soldier.
I feel like these are a little bit mutually exclusive, right?
will literally say unimaginably heinous anti-Semitic [__]
one day and then the next day he'll turn around and be like Like
what? What Where is that? the next day he'll turn around and
just like straight up repeat verbatim
Israeli talking points.
By the way, there's This is not actually an argument against
what I said. It's just an attack on the authority source
So, Asmongold thinks that Hasan's doing an actual like argument
here.
Like basically
This happens a lot where basically sometimes people expect and
it's very stupid cuz Asmongold definitely wouldn't do it. Sometimes
people expect that you're going to like source every single claim
you make every single time you make them. The idea that when
Asmongold says it's a small country, it's the size of New Jersey
and then he says you didn't even engage with my point when you
just called it Azbara. It's a obviously a point. The problem
people have with Israel isn't the size of the country. The problem
people have with Israel are the actions of the country. The size
of the country has nothing to do with the actions of the country.
Therefore, stupid point, right? But not everybody explains this
every single time. It basically slows the entire stream down,
right? Obviously, we're not doing this literally every time we
make any argument at all.
Okay? But it's very interesting when when somebody does this,
when they just basically make a point without citing it perfectly,
Asmongold's going to go, "You didn't even engage with me." that
he thinks that I'm using. It It's not even There's There's not
even another person who agrees with me. >> even relevant?
Um Oh my god. Did Did Did it Is there ever any point where an
argument is presented ever? Oh my god.
I mean [clears throat] bother or not >> There's nothing
that's even being said. He has a fairly large audience still.
Oh god. Uh obviously, it's uh diminished and as you know, Trump's
popularity. Right. I wasn't aware of that.
Even in the eyes of the uh the dumbest people alive, which are
the Euroid MAGA
>> Euroid? Oh, I like that. I've heard that
Euroid is a good one.
That's good. I like that. No, that's Euroid is terrible. Use
Angloid for the love of god, man. Um you know
I'll have to use that one. He loves talking sh-
about me, but No, I don't.
Hates the pro-
Hasan argued most of the kills were done by Israelis in some
cover on October
He argued most of the people who died on October 7th were because
of Israel. They died to Israel. Specter's talking to me. Of course,
right. Yes, I'm not giving him enough attention. Is that it?
No, I I I'm I'm being nice. Like I I'm usually very reasonable,
but it it it's
I know people who argue that. I've seen them argue that. I would
love to see
I would love to see Hasan argue that. I don't believe that's
ever been done, but
>> that Hasan has had a massive blind spot for making excuses
for, rationalizing, and justifying Islamic terrorism. It's undeniable.
You can look at it and look at it over and over and over. Meanwhile,
if you're going to call me a Holocaust denier, then why do we
ban all these people for denying the Holocaust? This seems a
little bit problematic. Why would I do that? Where have I ever
made content where I've denied the amount of people that were
killed in the Holocaust? It has nothing to do with this. He already
They already changed the title, but they're actually crazy. YouTube
doesn't [__] around with that stuff. Well, what is
this? Let me go back. I'll see if I can find it. And uh this
is from Destiny server. Did Okay, let me look at it and find
it.
>> where is it here?
Hasan calls Asmongold an anti-Semitic term Asmongoy in his new
I was GOING TO PULL THIS UP. I HAD this [__] pulled
up to go over it and laugh. Let's go. >> is a term used
by to call other non-Jews. It's not meant to be derogatory to
other
Wait, so [laughter]
I don't What is the argument? What is this? Uh is now used by
the far left and the far right as a term for non-Jews who aren't
anti-Zionist or anti-Semitic enough. Also on his main channel,
too. I just checked the title and now it says Asmongold is wrong
about
>> Maybe we should upload a video and have it say Hasan
is wrong about everything.
Oh god, that's funny. And so they changed it. I guess so. No,
and to be fair, it was my suggestion to call myself that, right?
I don't take offense. I think it's funny. Four
in one small screenshot.
Of course. I didn't see Theo Von. It's real. What the Oh my god.
Yep, there it is. And again, you're claiming about not being
derogatory is just what wrong. Well, again, like it I don't think
it's really a big deal to use the term. I don't really think
so. It's kind of a joke. [snorts] Asmongold just gets [__]
on how much he shills for the administration is definitely a
bigger threat than Hasan. Well, that's nice. I appreciate that.
is not necessarily anti-Semitic in nature. The is not necessarily
racist in
>> That's I mean soft A, that could be true. That could
be true.
That could be true.
The majority of people that were using on Xbox Live were not
racist. They were just stupid little kids. I was one [snorts]
of them.
Yeah, this is actually true. And everybody who's honest knows
that. We all know this. And I understand that there's optics
that you have to play into. Oh, well
By the way, just to be clear
You don't even press the buttons on the elevator in Israel on
Shabbat. It just goes up and down without anybody pressing the
buttons,
Just to be clear, I know that for a fact. I just I just make
the analogy cuz it's funny to me, okay?